Oh,
I just woke up and saw that you can check it out.
whether you got to be at the table or not.
Now I really do,
let's see if I got to be at the table.
Oh I was a clown.
Let's see if I really got to be at the table.
Help.
It has really been updated now.
Now it really comes out whether you have to be at the table or not.
My goodness.
The problem is that I've been there three times already and
supposedly those who have been there three times will not be touched anymore.
The problem is that I was a substitute and
it is not going to be their turn to play.
There is a high chance that I will be touched again.
Let's see,
you fucking zenemas,
you better not make me cursed.
A hijuep.
Ah,
what the fuck,
isn't it?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh,
it was my turn to be President,
how wonderful,
I am Chairman of the Peor table.
I can't believe it,
I dined dry ass,
I hate you.
Ah,
I can't believe it,
I can't believe it Damn it.
I have been there 4 times already,
this is my 5th time at the table.
How unfortunate they are.
I can't believe it,
I want to cry,
I want to cry
What a disgrace.
Yesterday I said yes,
than that
support those who have been at the table.
because I said he hadn't touched me and he did,
How wonderful,
I can't believe it.
Well friends,
see you at the table.
Ha ha ha
smile,
life is one.